[Musique]
de revoir cet endroit chaque année ans
l'état le plongeoir tout là-bas
et le sable de 5 ha et couteaux et les
carreaux
cette image ne change pas
e
la même plage et toi de dos
dans le même contre jour le même cadre
la même photo et quelques gens
andrea champ de ce bourdon
qui revient toujours
les sons
[Musique]
et elle et son devenir la cinquième
saison
qu'est-ce qu'on va bien pouvoir faire
de retour en septembre
à boire quelques verres
mais les jours je rechante qu'est ce
qu'on va faire d'extraordinaire
pour tout va deschamps
[Musique]
après novembre vient l'hiver
qu'on appréhende et qu'on espère
après la coupe leurs gains
le pollen et la poussière
laissons en verre
[Musique]
devenir la cinquième saison les sons
traire
et le son
venir la cinquième saison
[Musique]
la chauffeur
laisse entrer l'air
le grand air que l'on inspire que l'on
espère faire trembler les cloisons
[Musique]
essoufflé sur
faire nos griffures et nos vieux
cotillons
essoufflé
poussière les points du jeu quand
l'amour tournant
les assureurs
[Musique]
chan
venir la cinquième saison
c'est le les maisons
la cinquième chez jean les sons
[Applaudissements]
chanson
venir la cinquième saison
et les sous
devenir la cinquième saison ces gens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]